there's a chance that you're trying way
too hard to change your life you're
expending all of your willpower on
things that don't require it let me give
you an example I've been playing hockey
for about 20 years I'm going to be 27
this year and I've been playing since I
was like two feet tall so after 20 years
of conditioning what do you think
happens to me when I step inside a
hockey rink I immediately want to play
hockey I start thinking about scoring
goals the environment and the smells and
everything about being inside a hockey
rink creates a downhill slope that makes
me just want to play hockey but little
do we realize everything in our life is
like this especially the spaces that we
most commonly occupy even the smallest
things like the layout of our furniture
what foods are on display in our kitchen
every room in your house is telling you
to live your life in a certain way and a
lot of the time those ways are ways you
want nothing to do with and then when we
try to live our life differently or we
want to improve ourselves and improve
our habits it just feels like we're
swimming Upstream all the time we can't
figure out why nothing ever sticks we
feel like some other force is working
against us causing us to fail now I'm
not trying to perpetuate some type of
victim mentality I'm not saying that
there's nothing you can do about it your
environment is against you some third
party is involved and responsible for
changing your life in fact I'm saying
pretty much the exact opposite because
our Behavior shapes our environment and
in return our environment shapes our
continued behavior these things feed
into each other so let's talk about how
we can leverage this principle to use
our Behavior to shape our environment in
a smart way to create downward slopes
into living the lifestyle that you've
always wanted to live so the first thing
you should do is go room to room and ask
yourself what is the goal of this room
then observe all of the little features
of the room that are inhibiting that
intended purpose how do you make a
better bedroom well what's your bedroom
for it's probably for sleeping and
Alternative forms of exercise
so how do you create a environment that
Fosters those things that makes those
things better well first and foremost
you probably want that place to be clean
welcoming a nice warm comforting
environment so when you rest your head
on your pillow at night you're not
shaken to your core at the absolute
chaos that surrounds you so Step One is
probably to clean up your room don't
have lying around everywhere oh that's
no way to treat your clothes if you're
like me your bed takes up 85 percent of
the real estate of the room because I
live in a little closet but even with my
limited floor space I can still have a
nice little lamp in the corner maybe buy
a plant put up a mirror maybe a painting
buy one of those little closet
organizers get rid of a lot of the
clothes that I don't wear after I do
these things then all of a sudden
sleeping in my bedroom is just a more
enjoyable experience a change like that
can be restful it doesn't work that way
for me it works for your father you'd be
shocked as to how much better you'll
sleep in a clean room versus a chaotic
dank used underwear Laden Goblin hole
you know I bowl with your dad every week
he has a great time
another thing I noticed that was
seriously inhibiting my quality of sleep
was the fact that I was just on my phone
all the time before I go to sleep and
the minute I wake up there's a couple
ways you can tackle this in previous
videos I've suggested putting your phone
on a charging station across your room
at night so that you have no option but
to just sleep in your bed you can't go
on your phone if it's across the room
right
no that works great but honestly I have
a hard time sticking to that as well so
what did I do about it clearly I don't
have a ton of willpower at my disposal
so I bought blue blockers so when I'm on
my phone at night I'm not assaulted with
the blue light which inhibits my ability
to get into deep sleep here's the
trade-off though you're like okay you're
just gonna be on your phone in bed for
like three hours no what happens is when
I'm on my phone at night with my blue
blockers on all of the colors on my
phone are so washed out and my phone
charger cable is so short that it's just
so uncomfortable to be on my phone that
I don't go on it anyways and I go to
sleep the solutions don't have to be
neat and perfect but that's what's
working for me so I went from a messy
room with a long iPhone cable and no
blue blockers to just cleaning up my
room adding a couple decorations having
a shorter iPhone cable and blue blockers
and all of a sudden I'm getting way
better sleep they didn't say much but
you knew they were pleased as punch Now
we move move into the kitchen so what's
the goal of a good kitchen is it to [__]
around is it to sit there in despair as
you eat indomie for the fifth day in a
row feeling like [__] about yourself
no the goal of a good kitchen is
probably to make eating and cooking
healthy food as easy as possible so that
you can energize your body so that you
can go forward in life with exuberance
and Zeal so what does your kitchen look
like how is it inhibiting those
processes if you have different goals
for your kitchen that's all well and
good but for my kitchen I realized that
I was eating way too much junk food I
was buying things that I didn't actually
want to eat but I was buying them
because I was hungry in the grocery
store he was hungry and he had some
money so when I walked into my pantry I
asked myself do I want to eat indomie or
indomie because it's the only thing I
bought I mean I bought other things
healthier things but they're in my
fridge and it requires effort I have to
actually cook the chicken breasts chop
vegetables I don't want to do that I'll
eat the indomie do you see how dumb this
is through my purchasing decisions I
invited things into my house that were
counterintuitive to the way that I
wanted to live my life indomie is
extremely delicious and easy to eat and
it's very quick to eat so that when I'm
hungry I come into my kitchen and
basically the question is do I want food
now or do I want food in like 35 minutes
when I figure out the right way to cut a
chicken breast obviously I'm going to
choose the indomie I was existing in an
environment that created a downward
incentive slope into eating indomie so
what I did about it was two things first
of all obviously I stopped buying
indomie and other food that I don't
actually want to be eating and then
secondly I stopped buying chicken
breasts just to let it rot in my fridge
it's criminal to waste food like this
think of the sand wasp I started buying
other healthy foods that are actually
easy and quick to eat so that when I'm
hungry I can eat quickly and healthily
but Joey I don't know how to eat healthy
what are these good healthy foods that
are quick to eat that you're talking
about the first thing the first item on
the menu is what I like to call Advanced
granola I think it's technically called
moosely muesli I don't know how to
pronounce it but I'm sure you have this
in your grocery store it's got a bunch
of good stuff in it there's nothing like
sketchy but I like to get my oats in if
you respond well to oats it's high in
calories it's got good fiber I don't
just eat the oats because I'm not a
Madman I like to douse it in Ultra
filtered milk if you have this where
you're from in your country I would
highly recommend it because it's kind of
a cheat code the nutrition facts on the
back are insane it has so many vitamins
and nutrients in it and the protein is
way higher than regular milk and it's
lactose free so if lactose tends to make
you feel weird it won't be a problem
with this milk another thing I like to
eat all the time is eggs you can't go
wrong with eggs eggs are a superfood you
can only go wrong with eggs if you're a
vegan everyone knows I don't need to
talk about eggs just eat your eggs if
you're not morally opposed to it I don't
buy chicken anymore why am I morally
opposed to chicken no chicken's
delicious when other people cook it
chicken is sketchier to cook more food
poisoning involved I just buy steak now
because you literally can't go wrong you
slap it on a Hot Grill you can cook it
for like three seconds or three minutes
is still edible and it's like 40 grams
of protein good fats in there the final
thing I'm going to talk about is just a
little hack that I have and that's just
to have some grabbable vegetables grape
tomatoes can't go wrong with cucumber or
carrots just have things around you can
just grab when you're hungry little easy
solutions like this solve the problem of
like reaching for something like Doritos
reaching for something like indomie
doesn't need to happen there's healthier
alternatives to grab-and-go food
so I hope you enjoyed this little
breakdown
okay if you made it this far into the
video
look at the merch room look at all this
merch I physically have this merchandise
these inaction is a slow death hoodies
in my possession I lovingly pack it into
a box when you buy one actually Jared
does that [__] I don't touch it
this is hello but we've reintroduced the
merch for a limited time so if you want
a daily reminder that inaction is a slow
death cop the hoodies they're dope in
fact they're so dope and made with such
premium material that if you buy them
and you're an international person we
actually Break Even or lose money every
time you buy one so head on over to
betterideas.com get yours before they're
gone forever alright let's talk about
the house in general what is the goal
for a house what do you want the goal
for your house to be maybe you don't
have a house I don't own this one I'm
renting it maybe you live with 16
different people maybe you live in a
college dorm room maybe you live with
your parents whatever the case is you
have control over probably a small
section of it maybe it's just your
bedroom what do you want the goal for
that space to be for my own house I live
alone so I get to have a lot of control
over that question I get to have a lot
of control over the answers to that
question and for me I want to create a
space that I don't actually spend a lot
of time in you know I want to go be a
person in the world be part of
communities I want to go play hockey I
want to go for walks I don't actually
want to spend a lot of time in my house
being a recluse but while I'm here in my
little Goblin hole I want it to feel a
little less like a goblin hole I want to
create a space that recharges me and
refreshes me that's orderly where I know
where things are after a long day of
being a person in the world I want to
come home and feel like my life is in
order you know things are okay and I
want to eliminate sticky corners of my
house and what I mean by that is not
like a she-labs layer reference I want
to reduce sticky Corners like my office
when I'm at my worst I spend a lot of
time in my office in front of my 42 inch
OLED TV either gaming browsing the
internet or gaming and I don't want to
do that all day that's just sad
existence that's not me taking action
it's not me being a person in the world
injecting myself into the various
corners of the Earth
as sexual as that sound that's me
decaying that is exactly how I don't
want to live my life so try to figure
out the overall theme of whatever space
that you have control over ask yourself
what is the goal of this space how do I
want this space to help me live my life
how do I want my environment to help
shape my future Behavior because when
you figure out the answers to these
questions you might be shocked as to how
counter-intuitive your environment is to
achieving those goals and hopefully
through this video I've given you a
couple of ideas as to how you can tweak
your environment to create downward
slopes into the behavior that you want
to be doing so that living the life that
you want to live is as easy and as
simple and as irresistible as possible
this video is sponsored by athletic
greens ag-1 makes it insanely easy for
me to make sure that I'm hitting my
nutritional goals out of all of the
multivitamins or supplements that I've
ever taken athletic greens has by far
the most complex nutritional profile
packed with over 75 vitamins minerals
Whole Foods or superfoods and adaptogens
in every single scoop ag1 makes sure
that you're giving your body everything
it needs to feel energized and focused
throughout the day my favorite thing
about ag1 is that it's made from Whole
Foods so it ensures that it's extremely
bioavailable which means that your body
absorbs it very easily and you don't
just urinate it out like so many cheaper
multivitamins so if you're interested in
joining Me In by far the simplest way to
meet your nutritional needs then if you
use my link in the description below
you'll also get a year's supply of their
vitamin D3 and K2 complex which I also
have every single morning as well as
five ag1 on travel packs with your first
purchase so once again make sure to take
advantage of that link below and thank
you again to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video if you liked this
video then make sure that you actually
hit the like button because when you hit
the like button the algorithm blesses me
it blesses all of us and it shoves my
head into other people's home pages
helping them out it also helps me out
which is a win-win for everybody
involved so make sure that you actually
click the like button if you're lurking
here and this is these seventh time that
you've seen my face consider subscribing
also consider supporting the channel by
purchasing the better ideas merch the
interaction is a slow death embroidered
hoodie because once they're gone they're
gone they look dope they could return
again but at least that batch is gone
and we only release them in actual
physical batches it's not like this
automatic system that keeps on going and
going and going we buy a limited amount
and then we sell that and then we
consider buying more so that we can sell
those again make sure that you get yours
if you want it I'd sure want it this is
marketing me um trying to influence your
decision making
I am part of your environment and I'm
trying to influence your behavior
thanks for watching